parce que Monsieur Le Pen dit c'est vrai
parce que j'ai retrouvé un texte de lui
quand il était député et ça va tout à
fait dans le sens de ce qu'il dit
il peut pas lire ça dans ces meeting
il y en a qui l'ont pas entendu ce qu'il
faut dire aux Algériens c'est pas qu'ils
ont besoin de la France mais que la
France a besoin d'eux
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas dans le fardeau
ils sont une dynamique et le sang jaune
d'une nation française dans laquelle
nous les avons intégrés j'affirme que
dans la religion musulmane rien ne
s'oppose au point de vue moral à faire
croyant donc c'est vrai qu'il était pour
l'intégration et donc il y a plus de
raison qu'il fasse chauffer ces meeting
en donnant des musulmans à manger
aux fanatiques du Front national parce
qu'il est pas grotesque ensuite monsieur
pitre monsieur attention
il vous en cuirait parce que vous avez
vos garde du corps là